this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
minimalists
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists sometimes people
mistake minimalism for asceticism or
utilitarianism
but simple living is about isn't about
austerity or deprivation as minimalists
we're well we've discovered that beauty
is essential
and it's an essential part of life
and when we remove all the excess we
actually expose the everyday beauty
around us and that's why
irwin rafael mcmanus is back on the
podcast our returning champion yes erwin
thanks for being here it's good to be
back
i you know on this minimal we're going
to talk about beauty the genius of
beauty
the beauty of genius as well
and then on the maximal i thought we
would talk about well you've got a new
book you've got a new podcast series as
well called the genius of and we're
going to be talking about all of that as
well i want to dive deep into that but
first i thought we would start with a
question that we have here from tammy on
facebook
what exactly is beauty
when decorating a shared space how do we
agree on something that's objectively
beautiful it seems so highly subjective
and personal that it's difficult to find
agreement now erwin
you had this great line in our last film
which is lessons now it's out on netflix
that didn't make the film on such a
great line it ended up on the editing
room
that's right and so i figured why not
let's do a whole podcast about that this
line and so in fact during the intro
when i was saying that people often
confuse minimalism with utilitarianism
that was really the line you said i hope
people don't
confuse minimalism with utilitarian
because
beauty is
essential
absolutely let's talk about that well
let's go back to uh is it tammy's
question yes and
uh how do you define beauty yeah what is
beauty beauty is anything that provokes
wonder
oh
and tweet that podcast
that's that's awesome i i think it's to
me a fascinating contrast between art
and beauty not our no not all art is
beautiful even if it's compelling right
and so when a person is uh creating art
it can be motivated by all kinds of
emotions i mean art can be motivated by
hate it can be motivated by anger by
rebellion can be motivated by envy or
lust
and so for an art piece to be compelling
for it to even be
timeless it doesn't have to be motivated
by positive emotions
but beauty does
and so there's a difference between art
and beauty you can look at a work of art
and and recognize it's compelling but
not beautiful it doesn't evoke wonder it
doesn't evoke hope
and what i think is is essential that
hope is not necessary to create great
art but hope is absolutely essential to
create great beauty really and so when
you i mean when you go out into the
woods or you look at a waterfall you
look at you go to the ocean you see the
waves crashing against the rocks no
one's telling you an emotion to
experience that's right but you never
experience anger
or bitterness or despair you're not
watching a waterfall or sunrise and
going wow the world sucks
i'm so angry with life look at that
sunset
and what's to me is fascinating is that
there's some intrinsic human emotions
that respond without command
to beauty yeah and those emotions are
hope
and wonder aw
um if you would worship
yeah yeah oh i love that you know we uh
we've been working you know ryan and i
have been doing this whole minimalist
thing for the last 11 years or so and
we've crafted a message we helped a lot
of people heal their relationship with
stuff and with creativity and
and with people as well just all these
different relationships and
we wanted to find a way to really bring
the beauty of that forward it's why
we're in this new studio space and a lot
of it is actually inspired by what
you're doing over at mosaic you know
creating
art
that allows people to to see the beauty
sort of in everyday life and it can be
simple without it being simplistic and
that's what i've seen in what you're
creating
is that you are creating something that
is beautiful but it's not stark it's not
as you say utilitarian you can actually
go to different parts of the world and
see this architecture
uh you can go to places in the world
that have been heavily influenced by
let's say karl marx
and the buildings are stark and and
minimal but they lack beauty or
inspiration or imagination or hope yeah
and
when you look at government projects
that have been created how could you
possibly create government projects and
not know it would create violence
oh yeah and we and what's interesting to
me is when you when you have a high
volume of beauty you have a diminished
amount of violence yes it's really hard
to be violent when you're overwhelmed by
beauty oh
you can tweet that podcast sean now
let's get back to tammy's question here
because i think this comes up quite
often i'm living with someone else and
really what she's saying is my
preferences for beauty are different
from my partner's preferences or my
roommate or my significant other yeah
but isn't it that's going to be true
with anyone even if you have like my
wife and i have relatively similar
preferences but even then there's going
to be some tension between
what she appreciates and what i
appreciate what i find to be beautiful
versus what she finds to be beautiful
have you noticed this in your own life
oh absolutely i mean my wife is from the
mountains of north carolina and she is a
country girl and i am about as
cosmopolitan as a human being can be
and so our views of the world are so
dramatically different our view of art
or architecture is and in fact one time
she she heard this um
interior designer talk about how you can
know more about a person if you walk
into their bedroom in fact that's
actually true if you walk into someone's
bedroom you you can know whether to hire
them or not far more than a resume or or
an interview
and so my wife was listening to this
person she said so honey which part of
the heart the house reflects you
and i said uh none of it
and she goes what what do you mean i
said our house reflects how much i love
you
oh
but our house reflects you
wow and so for my birthday one year she
set aside a fairly sniffing amount of
money and said you can redesign this
bathroom
and so i actually blew everything out
and put this cave and and when you
walked inside the bathroom you turned to
rut you turned right and then you walked
into this cave there was rock and slate
and it looked like you'd gone
underground and there was waterfalls
that came out and flowed in different
directions and it was completely uh me
and uh and it was probably something she
had she probably hated that more than
anything else in the entire house yeah
and i and i probably was overkill for my
part but i got to actually design
something and have some fun it took me a
while and i think one of the realities
is that some people love monet and some
people love van gogh right one person
might love picasso another person might
like bansky and it doesn't mean the one
person's wrong or right and that's the
wonderful thing about beauty is it
eliminates wrong and right
see beauty isn't about wrong and right
that's it it's just like you know is
blue right or is red right
right and and we're raised in a world
where everything has to be good and evil
right and wrong good and bad yeah but
beauty actually eliminates that
conversation oh wow man that bathroom
sounds absolutely gorgeous man it was
actually quite nice and when we sold the
house it was the value added oh wow for
sure like literally quite literally you
know it's interesting i think about like
me and my wife and you know not just uh
our preference for beauty or what we
find beautiful you know there are a lot
of different preferences we have if it
was just with beauty that would be
awesome if that's the only differences
we ever had but of course there's more
but like you said you know i try to go
out of my way as much as possible to
allow her to express herself because i
do love her so much and she goes out of
her way to do that for me too in
different areas so yeah i mean i think
with any relationship whether it's a
friendship whether it's a romantic
partnership you know you've got to allow
room for each other's preferences and
that's where you know maybe tammy needs
to i don't know just kind of look at a
little bit how much are you opening up
uh your partners supporting your
partner's preferences how much are they
supporting your preferences
yeah i think some of though is also you
have to do you have to cultivate an
awareness of beauty
it's just like you cultivated an
awareness of good food
when kim and i were young we had a lot
of places we would never eat now and in
fact we sometimes think how many times
did we eat that fast food
because that's what we were raised on
right you know and as we matured and
grew and and had different experiences
we could never go back to some of those
places because all we could do is taste
the grease
or you can do is taste the salt yeah
right and so ironically sometimes people
think
they get the lessers wrong the less is
more wrong because uh mcdonald's may
seem like less but it's actually not
it's way more yeah right it's more of
all the things that are
killing us
way more of the wrong things yes you
know and
it's interesting how people say i don't
like this and then you ask them well
what happened when you tasted it oh i've
never tried it
and there's there's a difference between
i don't like it and i don't know it and
for many people i don't like it means i
don't know it mm-hmm
i don't know it is i don't like it yeah
so i'm afraid of it yeah it's funny
people say that about l.a all the time
oh la's so i can't believe you live out
in crazy land and la's so nuts i'm like
oh really like when did you visit oh
i've never been right but so
so pressing too difficult uh
i think too intensely in this ignorance
is an enemy of beauty oh
and sean tweet that yeah so my wife
hated oysters and she she hated oysters
because she had never tried one
and it was probably maybe five years ago
she was you know i mean i'm 63 now so
it's probably she was probably 57 years
old the first time she was willing to
try an oyster
and i love raw oysters and she'd always
just be so disgusted by it and then one
day we're on on the coast and she goes
okay i'll try one
i don't know what happened maybe it was
my birthday she just thought it'd be fun
she tried an oyster i set it up for her
i mean i put it together just for
fixings yeah yeah man and
when she ate it she just you could just
see something erupt inside of her she
goes this is my favorite food in the
whole world i go how did it go from i
hate oysters i will never try one dude
this is my favorite and of course it
ruined my life because now um i had to
share
now this tray of 12 became a tray of six
for me
and she just kept eating another one and
another another one i thought this is
what happens
ignorance is an enemy of beauty because
oftentimes we we don't actually know
what we're rejecting because we're
afraid to experience the new yeah and i
think a part of what keeps us open to
beauty is is an endless curiosity and
openness to try new things to experience
life in a new way oh man that's awesome
tammy i think there's an important
lesson in this is also understanding it
sounds like your preferences have
probably changed a little bit recently
maybe you're stumbling down the
minimalism rabbit hole you're letting go
of stuff and the things you thought were
beautiful are actually not beautiful to
you anymore but guess what it took a
while for you to get there and expecting
your partner or roommate or whomever to
change in 24 hours is also an
unrealistic expectation
we have a question here from corey in
virginia my question
today is actually uh for my sister
she has begun her minimalist journey and
she loves interior design
it's one of her passions she loves
you know redoing rooms and decorating
and all that stuff so how can you
implement
a minimus minimalist lifestyle
while still uh being able to
design your home
so corey thankfully we're here with
someone who really appreciates interior
design every time i go over to mosaic
it's one of the most beautiful places
i've ever been and
and part of that is it's beautiful the
way that an art museum or a gallery is
beautiful
quite often we walk into these spaces
and they seem empty-ish at first until
you realize like no it has everything
that is essential everything that makes
it beautiful sometimes the bones are the
beauty of the thing and then everything
within it serves a purpose it accents
the space there's a there's a beauty in
the having less
absolutely corey there's no
contradiction
when you're saying this
she wants to be an interior designer and
then she's trying to be a minimalist i'm
going all great interior designers are
minimal yeah they actually ask the
question what's what's the least amount
that creates beauty in this space right
people who are terrible at interior
design move towards clutter
they're the ones that have way too many
pillows
so
it's like you know the 20 pillows is not
interior design right right
that that's covering up something in a
way right and so
by adding more and more and it's funny
because like uh we remember we went to
the stall house a few years ago oh yeah
have you ever been up to the stall house
it's up in the hollywood hills and it's
gorgeous and they have all this really
nice furniture most of us from with
design within reach and but you could go
buy the same furniture and
not get the same aesthetic right because
someone has
very carefully curated exactly what goes
where and thought about it it's not
about simply
buying the thing i think quite often we
try to consume beauty we try to purchase
beauty and while we can buy certain
things that will augment or enhance the
beauty of something it can't simply be
purchased alone right yeah great
interior design leaves room for the
human experience
and so if you don't factor in how
the humans fulfill the space you've
already over designed it
man tweet that podcast on and so you
look around this space and uh you have
this beautiful
backdrop
but really what makes it beautiful is
that she didn't feel
it was necessary to fill every space yes
yeah and so the spaces speak and i'm not
really sure why but i was really young
you know my name is an alias so i always
struggled with
connecting to my name and then when i
had to sign my name when i was young
i didn't really know how to create a
signature and and so it's probably in my
teenage years i decided that i would
create and craft my signature based on
the spaces in between the lines
and what no one knew was my signature
was not the lines i drew but the spaces
in between the lines
and i think that really
a huge part of aesthetic is to
understand the spaces in between the
lines it's not just what we put there
it's it's what the space is in between
say
otherwise it becomes visual noise in a
way right and so when you think about
music what what makes beautiful music is
the space between the notes that's right
and i think the same is true for whether
it's interior design or it is art
or
even when it is a it's a book right it's
what are we saying between the lines
yeah absolutely even when in
communication
it's the power of silence that actually
makes communicators great yeah when you
when they somehow stop and there's a
silence and and all the thoughts that
have been pressing inside of you are now
catching up to you and that person is
giving you room to inhale
and that's a to me a part of the process
of communication is learning the spaces
in between the words yeah
man i'm i'm like so jealous of like your
uh ability to decorate and the same
thing with irwin because when i think
about like interior design at my place
it stresses me out because like i don't
i just don't have the eye for it i can
look at josh's place and be like oh wow
that's gorgeous i can look at mosaic i'm
like that is gorgeous but just copying
that doesn't feel right to me i'm like
oh man i would love to come up with my
own but yeah i don't know maybe i just
need to look at more minimalist design
work or something but i kind of let
mariah handle all the interior design
stuff or you can hire an interior
designer i mean that's the whole thing i
mean what we did for this space as we're
building it out you know we're only
about 70 complete but i'm not an expert
on lighting so we bring ev in who is
just a genius a savant of lighting and
he helps us out with that uh we brought
in beulah who did these beautiful
paintings but she also is helping out
with the rest of the space she picked
out the paint and the sound panels and
the couch and the credenza and all of
these things but she also really
understands what isn't here what
shouldn't go here so to speak right
because it's just going to clutter up
the space it's going to if we bring in
the wrong things it will take away from
the beauty of the space
and i think quite often the average
house has 300 000 items in it no wonder
we're so stressed out and things don't
feel beautiful to us we've covered up
the beauty that is sort of pre-existing
and by getting rid of that excess we are
all of a sudden uncovering some of the
beauty corey i'd love to send you a
couple tickets maybe bring your sister
on out to our washington dc event tk
coleman is going to be there with us in
washington dc he'll be with us in a few
other cities as well we're going to 20
different cities it's called the love
people use things tour we're gonna do a
minimalism talk we're gonna do a live
version of the minimalist podcast a book
reading q a all kinds of fun stuff every
major city across
the us we're gonna be there and canada
as well toronto and vancouver so come on
out the minimalists.com tour we'll reach
out to you cory give you a few tickets
to that washington dc event ryan what
time is it you know what time it is it's
time for the lightning round where we
answer your text messages you can text
your questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed now irwin you
probably remember during the lightning
round this is where we do our best to
answer questions with a short shareable
less than 140 character response we put
these texts uh these minimal maxims in
the show notes so you can copy and share
our pithy answers on social media if
you'd like urban has already like
had like how many pithy answers i know
we've already got 15 things on the show
notes from irwin
hopefully you and i will be able to come
up with something pithy here yeah we got
a question from stella how do we find
the beauty inside ourselves and then be
content with it
that is how do we find the essence of
who we truly are and stop trying to be
someone else wearing too much makeup
wearing certain clothes and brands to be
who we think others admire and look up
to and basically just trying to conform
to the impossible standards the beauty
and fashion industries sell us
what a beautiful question um and i think
there's something here or one about
how do i know what's me
versus
how do i
understand
what i'm trying to project into the
world
let's talk to stella about this we see
when i hear sela's question i don't hear
a question i hear an answer
and she already answered her question
and so i don't know what i can add to
that other than just say i think you
already found your path yeah defining
your essence so yeah so what is that
what is the answer in her question just
the well she's
i think the danger is to blame
everything around you
yes for not finding your essence
because no one can make you want
something
they can they can hit the button of
things you want
and you have to always hold on to the
why you want what you want yeah
and
you know and so i just look at things
and go
um
there's always going to be people
telling you here's a shortcut to be fine
to finding your own beauty and i think
that's really the question is are you
accepting a shortcut to your own beauty
because beauty really is about essence
about your character it's about whether
you're compassionate and kind and
forgiving and whether you're a person of
integrity and whether you bring hope and
joy to the world around you and so i
would say focus on the essence of who
you are and everything else will become
secondary
i love it
it's beautiful yeah there's about three
or seven things you can yeah tweet it i
got something pithy for you real quick
and i think it's mainly just echoing
what irwin has already said are you
wearing that t-shirt makeup and jacket
for you or are you wearing it to meet
someone else's expectation
because
if you are wearing everything for
someone else if you're doing everything
for someone else no wonder there's so
much discontent so much anxiety so much
tension
inside because
well you're not doing it for you in the
first place yeah i mean really
i feel like the only expectations that i
need to meet personally are my own like
those are the first expectations to me
and then look outwardly but if you can't
meet your own expectations then you're
certainly not going to find other
people's expectations fulfilling and if
it in indeed are your expectations even
yours right yeah because there are all
these sort of mimetic expectations
society has thrust upon us well you are
supposed to as erwin said earlier here's
what you should do you should buy a
house when you're 25 you should get
married at this age you should go to
college you should and some of these
things will certainly improve your life
but
is this actually your is this the path
you want to take yeah or are you running
down a path and at the same time running
away from yourself yeah
all right my pithy answer is this the
path to misery is paved with comparison
and we live in a world today where we
are constantly comparing we have these
comparison machines in our pocket
so you know if uh if stella here
is finding herself
filled with other people's expectations
i would ask her like well what kind of
entertainment are you taking in how much
social media are you looking at not only
that but like magazines or tv shows i
mean i had i realized when i first
started this minimalism journey how much
reality tv affected me how much gq
magazine affected me i had no id until i
started looking at these things so i had
to cut out a lot of the entertainment i
was consuming because it was it was
creating these desires that um really
weren't my desires
that's right
we got so much more to talk about but
first ryan you got something for us yeah
man here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners check them
out hey guys my name is jenny and i'm
calling from sheboygan wisconsin i
wanted to share a tip and trick
with minimalists that have a family my
husband and i recently became a family
of three welcomed our son micah into the
world six months ago and adding another
being to our lives can add a great deal
of physical items and items that are
outgrown really quickly
to honor our family's minimalism efforts
and living within our one family income
needs we met
um and went to a family member who has a
son one year older than our son micah we
asked them if we could borrow their baby
clothes and toys that they were storing
in their basement and bins just in case
they had another baby boy so we thought
that we could use them now rather than
them just collecting dust in their
basement
we have saved a great deal of time and
money by borrowing these items
and in turn we're storing them in our
basement as the family has a smaller
home and doesn't have space and they
didn't want to pay to rent a space
we have even started buying bigger
clothes and gifting them to the family
member as they will become ours in the
future when our son goes grows into that
size so we're creating this baby boy
clothes moving wardrobe and getting the
most out of each item by sharing them
with multiple families
this could work with family members or
friends co-workers of any listeners
that need a tip
it's a win-win for everybody
hi guys this is virgo from atlanta
georgia i just wanted to call as a
longtime barista i have a couple tips
about coffee i know you guys are coffee
people and own your own coffee shop
which is great by the way i love bandit
um i just wanted to tell listeners that
there's a really awesome coffee
subscription service called
tradecoffee.com
you can go in and put in your
preferences and what kind of you know
profiles you like
and um you can put in you know what your
brewing method is or whatever and they
will customize kind of um i guess what
coffee to send you and how often you can
tell them if you want it every week or
every two weeks like i do or every month
or however often you want to receive
your bag of coffee it's great roasted to
order specialty coffee and i have gotten
a lot of value out of it
and every bag is between 18 and 22
dollars usually
so it's um it's about what you would pay
at a specialty shop for a bag of coffee
and you can find new roasters to support
which is awesome
the other thing i wanted to share is
terracycle.com which is a service where
you buy
basically like a
a box and then you fill it with your
used coffee bags and they will recycle
them for you and you know anybody who
drinks a lot of coffee knows like it
sucks to throw away
all those bags um
but you know what are you gonna do with
them right so you can recycle them with
this service it's a bit of an investment
usually um it's like 35 for a small
pouch or you can go bigger i think the
biggest option is like a pallet which is
899 if you want to do that but yeah um
it's just an option for recycling those
bags um thanks guys all right y'all big
thanks to irwin rafael mcmanus you can
check out his new book it is called the
genius of jesus and his new podcast
series is called the genius of where he
dives deep in to exploring the genius
inside each guest that he interviews in
fact he did an interview with me over
there as well so you can check that out
real soon he also has a great podcast
with his son called battle ready where
they take two different sides of an
argument and sort of battle it out but
in a way that it forms a deeper
understanding between the two of them so
you can check that out as well we've got
a bunch more surprise questions this
week for irwin that's thursday on
patreon the maximal episode we call it
the minimalist private podcast you can
check it out each thursday the
minimalists.com
support
and you'll get a personal link so that
our private podcast plays in your
favorite podcast app real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist ryan since we've been talking
about beauty today
i thought we would take a peek inside
your
home and inside my home as well if you
haven't seen them already we have a
couple of minimalist home tours in fact
maybe it's time to do a refresh on yours
this was two apartments ago for you
yeah you know i was thinking about that
during the podcast about how your home
is picture-worthy and mine is so
mundane it's just a normal house like
people would walk into my house and they
wouldn't be like look at all this
minimalist design they would just be
like oh wow like
mariah and ryan keep things really tidy
so it's like i don't know long story
short i don't think it's very photogenic
but if you want to do it man i'm totally
willing to do it well check it out it's
the minimalists.com resources that's our
resources page a bunch of free resources
there we have a minimalism calendar we
have the home tours we have the values
worksheet we've got our simple sunday
email newsletter you can find all of
that on our website the minimalists.com
just click resources there at the top
for our added value this week ryan since
we've been talking about
beauty
this might be
if it's not my favorite song it's
certainly one of my favorites it's one
of the most beautiful songs that i've
ever yeah stumbled across our good
friend nate and drew
they um they have a band called parlor
hawk in fact they did all the music for
our last two films
uh they filmed a special or they formed
a special band called we
and did the soundtracks for minimalism
and lessons now but i first heard about
drew because he's the lead singer of
this band parlor hawk
and this song is especially
well noteworthy for an episode like this
because they built this giant song with
all these strings and violins and
different instrumentation
and they stripped it down to its essence
and there's only a few instruments left
in the song
the song is called scars by parlor hawk
by the way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like what are the
four things that make a genius a genius
how is the minimalist's message
different from marie kondo's method
how do we best explain the benefits of
minimalism to a maximalist
when you first started your minimalist
journey what hiccups did you encounter
how do we maintain our focus momentum
and motivation throughout the minimalism
cycle plus a million more questions for
irwin and the minimalist and if you want
to hear all that join us on the
minimalist private podcast this week
visit patreon.com
the minimalists to subscribe and get a
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app or you can just head on over to the
minimalists.com support that will take
you over there as well you'll get access
to all of our archives it's hundreds of
hours of minimalism all of our past
private podcast episodes our ask the
minimalists anything sessions and our
entire patreon community thousands of
other open-minded people who are
exploring what it means to live a life
with less you can follow the middle of
us on facebook twitter and instagram at
the minimalists come to one of our live
podcast shows visit the minimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com
comment on this episode youtube.com
slash the minimalists and if you want
our show notes in your inbox sign up for
our email list over at the
minimalists.com if you leave here today
with
just one message let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it